avete presente quello spezzone di uno
mattina in cui c'è un mago che si deve
esibire e appunto trovare la carta del
conduttore ma il trucco va a [ __ ]
questa maledetta carta non si riesce a
trovare e tutto lo studio rimane
impietrito e lascia il poveraccio a
morire in diretta tv
la maggior parte di voi avrà sicuramente
visto vi chiedo di tenerlo a mente per
dopo per adesso parliamo di breaking bad
e veramente tanto tanto difficile per me
parlare di breaking bad perché ho sempre
difficoltà a spiegare le cose che mi
piacciono piuttosto che raccontare
qualcosa che non mi è piaciuto e più
personale cercare di raccontare qualcosa
che ti piaciuta qualcun altro non so
neanche bene da dove partire per
iniziare il discorso ma la facciamo che
iniziare con una similitudine tanto sarà
la prima di molte breaking bad per me è
una macchia arancione in mezzo a un mare
di grigio me è una storia raccontata
dall'inizio alla fine senza neanche una
virgola fuori posto
e semplicemente una delle migliori serie
che io abbia mai avuto il piacere di
vedere vi avverto subito che in questo
video ci saranno in al mare a di spoiler
dall'inizio alla fine
perché non lo faccio tanto per chi non
l'ha mai visto per kim ed anzi lo faccio
proprio per chi l'ha già finito più
volte magari ea magari anche a chi non è
piaciuto non è neanche una recensione
semplicemente la mia opinione su una
cosa che io adoro e perché lo adoro beh
sono sicuro che uno dei motivi
principali è perché io questa serie l'ho
iniziata quando era in corso la terza
stagione quando praticamente la gente ne
parlava elogiandola ma non era ancora
diventata un fenomeno di massa
io ho fatto come tutti gli altri
telefilm ho letto l'incipit vi è
piaciuto ho iniziato al mare
e me ne sono innamorato subito se ci
fate caso adesso la gente dice sempre e
le prime due stagioni non sono un
granché ma dalla terza carbura cosa che
non mi è mai stata detta per
nessun'altra serie mentre per quanto mi
riguarda la prima stagione bella tanto
quanto la quinta e questo perché quello
che ha sempre contato in breaking bad
sono i personaggi le loro emozioni loro
fallimenti le paure le ansie e le
angosce i rapporti umani tra volte la
famiglia travolte jazz e da lì che si
parte poi per farti piacere l'intera
serie perché se a te frega qualcosa dei
personaggi ti frega anche di quello che
gli sta succedendo intorno se tu dalla
prima puntata inizia a pensare oh mio
dio non me ne frega assolutamente nulla
di questi personaggi quali potrebbe
anche cascare un meteorite enorme in
casa mi struggendo lì era in mille pezzi
e uccidendo tutti quanti
e tu e con le chip che io ho letto tanti
tanti anni fa di breaking bad che era un
professore di chimica scopre di avere il
cancro e quindi inizia a vendere
metanfetamina e un inizio perfetto per
avere un tipo di sviluppo dei personaggi
che io adoro uno dei pezzi più belli
delle prime puntate nel rapimento di
crisi e li possiamo vedere come molte
white sia ancora soltanto un professore
di chimica contro che non ha la benché
minima idea di come comportarsi avendo
in casa un ostaggio non sa se tenerlo in
vita non sa se ucciderlo quindi inizia a
dargli da mangiare e inizia a parlarci
vuole conoscere questa persona a cui sta
facendo tutto questo male vuole
conoscere crisi ed è giallo scoprire il
suo vero nome non a nome di strada
accende un barlume di speranza e molte
che dice ah forse posso non ucciderlo
perché alla fine un ragazzino come tutti
gli altri
ed è qui che breaking bad e tipi uno
schiaffo in faccia e gli dice [ __ ]
le regole le faccio io perché ho il
mondo dello spaccio e fatto da figli di
[ __ ] guarda un po e si arriva quella
splendida realizzazione dove walt
costruisce un piatto manca un coccio
capisce che c'è la crisi e hite per
difendersi lo uccide e tutto questo che
io vi ho raccontato in pochi secondi
succede nell'arco di un'intera puntata
perché gli sceneggiatori hanno voluto
dare lo spazio
sto guarda un po alle emozioni da lì in
poi è tutto in discesa o in salita
dipende dai punti di vista
la paura di dover uccidere qualcuno
viene man mano surclassata dalla voglia
di successo dalla voglia di potere ma
senza mai essere trasformato in un
mostro perché l'enorme quantità di soldi
che guadagno non gli fa comunque perdere
la paura di dover veder morire un tuo
parente per tutto l'arco delle quattro
stagioni un walt ci ripete che quello
che lui sta facendo e per la famiglia e
non a caso ho detto quattro stagioni
nonostante siano 5 ma la quinta da
prendere a parte questo perché perché
secondo me non c'è il walt alcuna
trasformazione
noi lo vediamo all'inizio come un povero
professore malato terminale che poi si
trasformino in king pil della droga ma
secondo me lui è sempre stato così
e qui prende in prestito una frase del
mondo tonali chi poter cenci perché tu
per esempio non impari a mentire pian
piano durante il corso della tua vita tu
sai già mentire ma non ne hai mai avuto
l'occasione
esattamente come per molto semplicemente
le circostanze gli hanno tirato fuori le
sue abilità oggi è veramente difficile
parlare in generale di qualcosa sto
perdendo pezzi per strada come tutti gli
altri personaggi per esempio skyler la
moglie per esempio che viene bistrattata
da tutti quelli che l'hanno visto brevi
mezzo quando in realtà se ci pensi è
quella che ha più ragione a che dà
fastidio perché tutti i fiper gol ma in
realtà quella che ha ragione lei perché
lui che sta facendo tutte le stronzate
illegale viene insultata dal figlio la
sorella il cognato non possono aiutarla
perché lei non può dire niente a loro è
come se tutto il giorno prima se
disoccupato il giorno dopo territori a
dover riciclare i soldi di tuo marito
che spaccia metanfetamina blu e direi
che tutti i suoi sfoghi sono pienamente
giustificati poi c'è il figlio che prima
non dice ditemi tutto quello che succede
poi quando glielo dicono chiama la
polizia
ok poi c'è haneke che uno dei personaggi
secondari più importanti
non solo perché il cognato di volte ed
enel antidroga e ricollegandoci
all'argomento emozioni si può notare
come il viso di hank cambi da un certo
punto nella serie poi esattamente dopo
la sparatoria dei due cugini di tubo
quando è che finisce in ospedale semi
paralizzato da lì in poi la sua faccia
diventa nera buia di rabbia non sorride
quasi più accesa una mezza battuta solo
quando in presenza dei suoi colleghi ma
quando è a casa o e da solo e nero con
mari che poverina si deve prendere tutte
le sue mire addosso ad hoc e confusione
di video però sapevo che sarebbe venuto
fuori così perché io volevo parlarvene
in ogni modo tecnico non ho voluto
parlarvi della regia cristallina che
avrei king bed l'accenno soltanto ma
perché ci sarà sicuramente ingente che
non potrà parlare molto meglio di me di
questa cosa qua vedo solo due valori che
suggerisce poi parliamo della quinta
stagione chiudiamo cessi e il figlio
adottivo di mori lo tratta esattamente
come tratterebbe un padre figlio che
anche se ai 27 anni i tuoi dialoghi sono
come se ne avessi 2 ogni cosa che fa è
sbagliata e avrebbe potuto farlo in un
altro modo ogni scelta che fa è
sbagliata avrebbe potuto prenderne altre
mille e questo work borsa e glielo
ripete in continuazione ma non perché
sia stronzo walt non solo per quello ma
perché vorrebbe veramente vederlo
cambiare in meglio lo rincuora quando ne
ha bisogno gli fa pochissimi complimenti
perché altrimenti lo renderebbe debole
questo e molto altro il settimo cielo
il rapporto è spesso difficile e confuso
non riescono a comunicare come
dovrebbero ma credo che un pochino in
fondo in fondo si vogliono bene a parte
nella quinta stagione
parliamo della quinta stagione la gente
si lamenta del fatto che un walk passa
dalle prime quattro stagioni ad essere
uno che appena entrato nel mondo dello
spaccio repentinamente ad essere
diventato in villa in dei fumetti
praticamente senza cuore troppo freddo
troppo distaccato ed è vero anche lui è
sicuro di essere diventato così ma in
realtà no per me tutta la quinta
stagione e gira intorno ad una frase che
mai che gli dice dopo che lui uccide gas
che cosi chassis gen
da chiedersi la traduco e il
reinterpreto per i babbani davvero
ucciso gas non fa di te
cass e questo si nota dalla miriade di
errori che lui fa in ogni singola
puntata della quinta stagione e questo è
quello che di solito ne america si
chiama fall out cioè banalmente
raccogliere quello che hai seminato
e tutto questo porta poi al finale il
finale di serie anche qui non solo la
gente si è divisa per l'intera quinta
stagione ma si sa in quanti più
frammentata per il finale mi è piaciuto
si è spettacolare come pensavo no ed è
questo il problema
tutti si aspettavano un finale dove morì
a tutti una strage incredibili skyler
tagliata a metà il figlio senza gambe
che cammina strisciando sangue paratoria
in città palazzi che crollano esplosioni
gigante godzilla che a un certo punto
arriva ad alba clerc inizia a sparare la
gpu della bocca
no niente di tutto questo breaking bad è
il finale
il finale di una storia dovevano
chiudere 10 sottotrame hanno chiuso 10
sottotrame è morto chi doveva morire si
è salvato chi si doveva salvare e la
telecamera pian piano si allontana dal
corpo di molte dicendoci dai maya e
ripetono in finale mi è piaciuto e anche
molto ma è un finale come un altro nel
senso si è chiusa la storia appunto a
parte una sola volta non c'è mai stato
nessun finale che mi abbia fatto gridare
al miracolo
l'unico è stato deciso per amor di dio
guardate di the shee quello è stato
l'unico finale che dopo averlo visto
fissato il muro per tre ore ripetendo
wow
ma cani ma è solo per questo che
breaking bad ti piace così tanto
no ed è qui che ci ricolleghiamo al mago
di raiuno mentre tutti quanti
dono per la gaffe del mago che non
riesce a trovare la carta io invece mi
immedesimo in lui e provo quello che ha
provato lui un enorme stretta allo
stomaco provocata dal disagio nel
momento per me breaking bad e questo mi
piace perché mi provoca disagio ad ora
avere mal di pancia dovrà avere le
emozioni fuori posto e che sia
avvelenare un bambino far scontrare due
aerei ma andare all'ospedale un
poliziotto investire due spacciatori
nemici o veder morire dei protagonisti
breaking bad
ce la fa al cento per cento per me
guardare questa serie equivale allo
stare seduto in una stanza con una
scatola di cartone davanti al cui
interno c'è una bomba che non ha idea di
quando esploderà